colette bettié marly trois couturières
au service du chum
dès l'appel lancé pour l'opération
solidarité masque elles n'ont pas hésité
une seconde à mettre leur talent au
service de la bonne cause c'est une
période où l'on a besoin de tous pour
combattre le coronavirus et pour aider
les docteurs et infirmiers pour qu'ils
puissent lutter contre cette maladie
dans cet atelier on achève une série de
blues jetables pour le personnel médical
tout est fabriqué dans des conditions de
sécurité maximale pédiluve à l'entrée
gel hydroalcoolique masque distances de
sécurité sans compter une chaîne de
production gérée par une ingénieur
industriel
josefina prépare tous les éléments et
vérifie la qualité des blues pour la
production des prêts par la production
voilà effet mais aussi et les bancs
d'école également par exemple je
m'assure d'avoir de plus tous les jours
et s'il ya des soucis d des plus d'une
trentaine de stylistes modélistes a déjà
été sélectionné par la chambre de
métiers de l'artisanat
bientôt ces artisans fabriqueront des
blues lavables pour le personnel non
soignants et des masques réutilisables
homologué une initiative qui permet au
chum de pallier le manque de matériel de
protection
là nous nous sommes mis en action pour
trouver des fournisseurs trouver des
couturières trouver
des merceries trouver le type de masque
qu'il fallait faire et puis nous sommes
tournés vers les les autorités pour
qu'ils nous aident à mettre en place ce
projet cinq mille doses et quatre mille
masques sont en cours de préparation et
grâce à l'élan de solidarité
la production devrait être prête dans
une semaine